hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to cluster truck now this
game has been requested a whole bunch I
haven't gotten to it because I've been
incredibly lazy and also incredibly busy
holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] just happened oh my god
that's so cool I saw a video of this on
reddit like a long time ago and I know I
I know that I should have played it like
a suit escaped [ __ ] god dammit
anyway I should have played this sooner
and haha got him bad I'm gonna be good
though nope no no that's the opposite
truth okay I've been playing a lot of
Ben and Ed and I actually was playing it
for like two and a half hours straight
doing this in furia why why would you do
that okay
okay why would this infuriatingly
difficult level that involves a lot of
jumping like this so I thought what
better way to finish my night then to
play another infuriating possibly game
that's gonna make me drive myself insane
with absolute horrendous jumping
abilities that I have except this time
it's in first person ever the passion
it's in first-person perspective [ __ ]
come on I can do this I know it I've
been jumping tricks my whole life I was
like born in the matrix I am the one and
why are those falling wait are they for
oh my god they're falling now holy [ __ ]
that's amazing I would love to play this
in virtual reality and it seems like
everyone's been getting their VR
headsets except for me where's my VR
headset oh [ __ ]
ah okay alright I don't know what kind
of shipping lane that this is for these
trucks here but it doesn't seem very
efficient and/or safe I've quite a few
OSHA concerns and if you don't know what
OSHA is you're probably too young to
worry about that sort of stuff but OSHA
is something about hazardous materials I
believe anyway what the [ __ ] is that
what can the highway has right oh [ __ ]
yeah oh
and landed perfectly everyone is safe
and sound
holy tits no one survived that holy [ __ ]
also my voice is like totally gone
because I had been yelling in rage for
about two hours straight
and I'm ready for anything to bring me
any sort of [ __ ] any sort of joy then
what I just o'clock any sort of joy then
what I just experienced I think you want
you want to go bro high you want to go
huh [ __ ] you gosh I've gone the wrong
way
oh okay we're fine everything [ __ ] yep
okay
so what I gotta do is I gotta be better
and I'm not good but I'm good enough I
misjudged that no I didn't [ __ ] yes I
did I forgot
all right just go left go left buddy go
left left left
Oh God that's not good I'm not gonna
make that [ __ ] I just got my skull
fracture ten million places [ __ ] just
miss miss miss me miss me ah [ __ ]
okay keep going keep going you got it
roll over the bones totally fine
everything's cool everything's chill oh
god we're all scot-free just ignore the
dead bodies of your fallen comrades
[ __ ] keep going oh god oh god oh god oh
god we're fine everything's fine
okay come on load of ass okay [ __ ] I'm
gonna get on this one [ __ ] no I'm not oh
god where am I I have no idea where I am
okay we're fine everything's fine
everything's NOT fine
oh not fine not fine hey where am I I
don't know what the hell just happened
I'm on the belly of the beast huh
let me get on you let me on you and
we're fine they're coming after us they
didn't want me to survive but it's so
kind of rogue man jumping on our trucks
oh [ __ ]
ow my face and skull and brain yeah okay
we're fine whoa [ __ ] holy crap oh my god
my skull [ __ ] yeah II there you there we
go all right just don't knock me off
you got delicate cargo up here meaning
my tiny pea-sized brain is about to be
pancake why did I go forward boom holy
[ __ ] wha holy SH holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] where am I oh whoa hey by god damn
it [ __ ] by God by [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] balls ass okay we're fine we're
fine we're fine just gotta look forward
left okay on the right oh [ __ ] stop
moving the train to get me off they're
trying to ah where am I [ __ ] they ran me
over and died I bet I bought we all died
whoo okay I got this one okay now that
I've honed in my skill [ __ ] okay that'll
work
don't know how I did that one but I did
it and I'm happy [ __ ] okay [ __ ]
Oh shush as Dan said [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] how
did I do that
I didn't not like that oh [ __ ] oh hey if
I just ride in the front I'll be fine
hey if I just write here I'll be totally
okay right why do you want me so badly
why do you want to kill me so badly I'm
just trying to hitch a ride or
hitchhikers really that bad really
come on be kind be nice everything is
okay okay level 18 what happened to when
Wham how did I get to level 18 I don't
know I skipped through a whole bunch of
other levels oh my god they're all dying
cuz they're careening off this oh oh no
oh no oh no whoa no
Oh Warner for no no you're not getting
me like that
[ __ ] I got myself if I can't have me no
one can if anyone can get me no one will
if I won't get there that no one will
get anywhere
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh god oh god oh god oh the
platforms are moving I didn't realize
that's what was happening okay ah yeah
ah [ __ ] Hey
oh this these guys are all oh I picked
the winner I think the winner might be
up there but I'm not not to 100% sure
about that one
I think the one I think I think this is
the winner I think I think this one yeah
this one's the winner hey get off my
winner I'm gonna hop over this one cuz
you're no longer the winner in my book
bye hey level 23 is it based on how good
I do probably I'm really good at this
game
hello okay then jeez where are we going
oh my god why do they blow up I mean
their trucks oh that makes sense
oh god this seems bad don't worry I'll
counterbalance ya [ __ ] I don't know what
happened but I'm pretty sure I died oh
hello this game would be really a lot
better if it add sound effects but this
is just an alpha that anyone can
download at the moment the real game is
uh coming to steam huh sometime soon
sometime soon oh good let me up yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] who's still going anybody
is anybody still going you're still
going there's my champion Oh fine okay
okay here we go
don't blow up you're gonna blow up
aren't you damnit oh [ __ ] okay okay okay
alright we're okay we're okay oh god
damn in my one target decides to go away
what a piece of [ __ ] alright I gotta use
my slow-mo a little better whoa okay
don't know where I am
but I'm okay oh my face oh here we go
oops I think oh that ain't good
that's what you would call not good oh
[ __ ] got it nailed it nailing it nailing
it who the [ __ ] is doing that what the
hell no that's that's not good oh I've
made it I guess shed oh it was that way
no one told me okay so far so good so
far so good that's not good not good not
good not good not good not good not good
let me up let me up let me up okay we're
okay we're okay okay now we're gonna go
counter Wumpus to the direction that we
went just like yeah Oh like a butterfly
oh that's not like a butterfly okay ow
God no giant blocks of ice get out here
yay oh oh I got it oh I did it
hey go goomy oh [ __ ] don't go me go me
not go me no no no me no no okay Wow oh
thank you
[ __ ] the one gap the one gap I can't hit
the one damn ah I can't hit the one gap
very easily boink
thank you don't even need my slow-mo I
know I'm just that good look yeah
okay there's a five pick the one is a
load of ass
yeah man effects and hook [ __ ] whoo hey
how you doing hey hi swim I just saw my
failure in slow-motion it didn't help me
at all
[ __ ] I can do this level I can do it I
can do it this game is awesome by the
way it's it's absolutely awesome holy
[ __ ] is it awesome
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] ah [ __ ] tits
I mean fudge I mean [ __ ] ah [ __ ] like
ass whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa
I picked up a lot of speed out of
nowhere [ __ ] oh hey Oh nailing it thank
you
I needed this I'm taking this I'm taking
advantage of the situation by needing
this kind of how the [ __ ] am I gonna get
over there I don't know oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god damn it ha ha yeah
Bank yes yes yes I am amazing in every
way except for when I fail then I'm not
amazing at all ok oh god oh god huh Wow
I just thrust myself into death when I
see failure approaching okay so that is
cluster truck it is absolutely awesome
I'll provide a link for the game that
you can play it in the content above but
in the description below and let me know
what you think in the game maybe I'll
play it again get farther into the
levels it's totally awesome it's coming
out on Steam soon and hopefully when it
comes out it will have a bit more
fleshing out on the sound effects aspect
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye you're trying
to escape the stampede of elephants that
are trying to oh this is not gonna go
well do I have a bomb to have a bomb
missing balls why am I going the wrong
way where am I going
what am i a gun oh okay